get started
don't wait for conditions to be perfect
before you actually do something because
by the time you figure it all out you'll
have missed your window of opportunity
you have to get started and get started
today do something even if it's a small
thing start building some momentum i got
a question from valerie who's a youtube
viewer
love you guys on youtube wrote in you
know i have the equipment to do a
youtube video i want to get started on
youtube but i have to find somebody to
help me set this up for my business what
do i do
you don't need somebody valerie you can
start on your own don't wait for
somebody else to get in this for you to
start making a successful youtube video
start and if your goal is to build
something big with it you will find
resources people connections to help you
out
when i first started on youtube i wanted
to do it because i was a visual learner
i wanted to be able to share and answer
the same question a lot of people are
having instead of just helping that one
person i could put on youtube make a
video and help tons of people that was
the main goal and my first video sucked
you know i was nervous the camera
equipment was was terrible the lighting
was off the sound was off but i just
started
that's the key you start you look at the
product that you create you want to make
it better
you have standards right you want to
start increasing the quality here
and part of that's going to come from
you doing research
so i research better cameras i
researched tripods i researched
microphones i came from feedback from my
users the people who are watching videos
said i love the video but the sound
quality kind of sucks
so okay i got to get a microphone
and i started improving the quality
gradually
i brought on a team of people to help me
so
i do the videos myself so i'm in my
office i've just got a sony camcorder or
handycam whatever it is i got a sony
microphone it's sitting on a tripod
and i film it and then i put it on my
google drive and i have a contractor
someone on my team who edits all the
videos
so i started editing myself and they
were crappy like they were basic editing
but it doesn't matter like you don't
need editing just put it up get started
build some momentum don't wait to find
the perfect editor before you start this
thing go start doing it practice you'll
get better
i found an editor i use odess which is a
great service
and she works for me every week
christina she's watching this video hey
christina love your work awesome keep
doing a good job and i send all the
files to her we use google drive i
upload them on my camera she puts them
uh on my youtube video channel she'll
put uh the name description all that
stuff she posted because my time now is
best spent making the videos so that's
what i do
and i've slowly built up my equipment my
technology the people who've
helped me
and i'll talk to people who are in video
and who are in
who are photographers and i say look at
my video what do you think could they be
better and they give me tips on lighting
and they give me tips on setting the
stage and distracting background all
this stuff that you learn
because you want to get better
but if you keep just learning and you
never take any action and you keep
waiting for the right person to come
along nothing is gonna happen you have a
great idea built up in your head and
you'll never take action you look back
it's like two years have gone by and
nothing has happened
so it's great to plan like plan it's
great keep that plan in mind but also do
something about it
to make a youtube video is easy
you have a camera you use your laptop
anything some kind of camera press
record start sharing your opinion make
it as powerful as impactful as you can
care about your audience
and just put it up
and it'll get better and better and
better and better and that momentum of
you actually doing work will feed
into making those videos better
and before you know you have an amazing
product on your hand with all you do is
plan you're never going to make it and i
know
i know it's hard
a lot of us are planners
a lot of us want to have everything done
perfectly before we do something and
it's and it's a fear
of something going wrong and it not
working out and it's a legitimate fear
right you don't want to create something
that sucks and it's a big failure
but you also have to work through that
fear
and not just plan i know a ton of
entrepreneurs who just plan plan plan
plan plan and and take some forever to
do something
and as a result they're building a
company that's a fraction of what it
could be
so you need to combine the planning with
actual action
so plan for your youtube channel or
whatever project it is for you the rest
of you guys watching plan for it but
also start do something now do something
today small record a video even if you
don't post it record a video on your
camera
just to see what you look like practice
make it as good as you can
build some momentum it'll feed into your
business make you better make your
company better make you more money
believe
you guys like this video thumbs up below
thank you so much it makes me want to do
more videos for you and i want to hear
you have to think comment below please
for those of you watching you like the
video please leave a comment even just
say i like this video those make my day
every day when i eat my breakfast and
i'm watching the videos and if you have
a question for your company leave it
below i will make a video response for
you just like i did for this one thank
you guys i'll see you soon